so i don't know if you heard but neil
young and other musicians have kind of
spoke out and saying they're going to
leave the platform because
uh
joe rogan is allowed to be on this
platform having these kinds of
conversations with the likes of robert
malone
and it's clear to me that spotify and
youtube
are being significantly influenced by
these extreme voices like you mentioned
on each side
it's also clear to me that facebook is
the same and it was going back and forth
in fact that's why facebook has been
oscillating on the censorship is like
one group gets louder than the other
depending on whether it's an election
year
it's uh there's several things to say
here so one it does seem i think you put
it really well
it would be amazing if these platforms
could find mechanisms to listen to the
center
to the um to the big center that's
actually going to be affected by the
results of the our pursuit of scientific
truth right
and listen to those voices i also
believe that most people are intelligent
enough
to process information
and to make up their own minds like
they're not
in terms of
um this
it's complicated of course because we've
just been talking about advertising and
how people can be influenced but i feel
like if you have
raw long-form
podcasts or
programs where people express their mind
and
express their argument in full
i think people can hear it to make up
their own mind
and if those arguments have a platform
on which they can live then other people
could provide
better arguments if they disagree with
it and now we as human beings as
rational as intelligent human beings can
look at both and make up our minds
that's where social media can be very
good
at like this collective intelligence
we together
listen to all of these voices and make
up our own mind humble ourselves
actually often you know you think you
know
like you're an expert say you have a phd
in a certain thing so there's this
confidence that comes with that and
the collective intelligence uncensored
allows you to humble yourself eventually
like as you discover
you know all it takes is a few times you
know looking back
uh
five years later realizing i was wrong
and that's really healthy for a
scientist that's really healthy for
anybody to go through and only through
having that open discourse can can can
you really have that that said spotify
also
just like pfizer is a company
which is why
this podcast
i don't know if you know what rss feeds
are
but podcasts can't be censored so joe's
in the unfortunate position he only
lives on spotify
so spotify has been actually very good
at saying we're staying out of it for
now
but rss this is pirate radio nobody can
censor it's the internet so
financially
in terms of platforms this cannot be
censored which is why uh podcasts are
really beautiful and so if spotify or
youtube
wants to be
the host of podcasts
i think where they flourish
is um free expression
no matter how crazy
yes but i do want to
push back a little bit on what you're
saying
because i have um anti-facts friends
who i love
and they're dear cherished friends
and they'll send me stuff
and it'll take me
an hour
to go through what they sent
to see if it is credible
and uh usually it's not
it's not a random sample of the
anti-vaxx argument i'm not
saying i can disprove the anti-vaxx
argument but i am saying that it's
almost like we were talking about
how medical science clinical trials the
presentation of clinical trials to
physicians could be improved and
the first thing we came up with is to
have pre-publication transparency in the
peer review process yes so bad
information biased information doesn't
get out as if it's legitimate and you
can't put it back recapture it once it
gets out
i think there's an element of that in
the
arguments that are going on about
vaccines and they're on both sides but i
think the anti-fax side puts out more
units of information
claiming to show that the vaccines don't
work
and
i guess in an ideal situation there
would be real time fact checking by
independent people not to censor it but
to just say
that study was set up to do this and
this is what the conclusions were so the
way it was stated uh is on one side of
this argument but that's what i'm
arguing yeah i agree with you what i'm
arguing is that this big network of
humans that we have that is the
collective intelligence can do that real
time if you allow it to if you encourage
people to do it and the scientists as
opposed to listen i interact with a lot
of colleagues a lot of friends that are
scientists
they roll their eyes their response is
like ugh
like they don't want to interact with
this but it
that that's just not the right response
when a huge number of people believe
this
it is your job as communicators to
defend your ideas it is no longer the
case that you go to a conference and
defend your ideas to two other
uh nerds that have been working on the
same problem forever i mean sure you can
do that but then you're
rejecting the responsibility you have
explicitly or implicitly accepted when
you go into this field that you will
defend the ideas of truth and the way to
defend them is in the open battlefield
of ideas and become a better
communicator
and i believe that when you have a large
you said you invested one or two hours
in this particular but that's little
ants interacting
at scale i think that uh allows us to
progress
towards truth at least you know
at least i hope so i i think you're an
optimist i i want to work with you a
little bit on this
let's say um a person like joe rogan who
by the way had me on his podcast and
left an amazing conversation i really
enjoyed it well thank you i did too and
i didn't know joe i didn't know much
about his podcast he pushed back on joe
a bunch which is great
and he was love it he was a gentleman
and we had it out in fact he put one
clip
at one point he said something that was
a little bit wrong and i corrected him
and he had the guy
who jamie jamie he had jamie check it
and was very forthright in saying yeah
you know john's got a right here you
know we got to modify this in any of
that
in any event you got them
yeah well i did i wasn't trying to get
them no just right now yeah yeah totally
it was there's a beautiful exchange
there's so much respect in the room
pushing back and forth that was great
yeah so i respect him and
i think
when he has somebody on
who's a died in the wool anti-faxer
the question is how can you
balance
if it needs balance
in real time i'm not talking about
afterwards i'm talking in real time
maybe you record well he does record it
obviously but maybe when there's a
statement made that is
made as if it's fact-based
maybe that statement should be checked
by
some folks
who
imaginary folks who are trustworthy and
in real time as that discussion is being
played on the podcast
to show what independent
experts say about that claim
you